hello folks
uh let's get started of the webinar so
all of us are here today uh to
learn about the three steps to a dream
big data role
this webinar is intended for our simply
learn hadoop students so that
they can easily navigate the complicated
world of big data skills and roles and
you know achieve their career potential
as you know big data is being used
across industries there are variety of
technologies that are being used there
are different kind of roles
and you know and it's an emerging field
so there's a lot of new updates and a
lot of things that only somebody with a
lot of industry experience
and a lot of
industry knowhow will know so we
requested our
big data influencer
lillian pearson so that she could you
know
chart out the whole big data scenario
the various domains that are there the
various skill sets that are required the
various job opportunities
that are there so that you can take an
informed
decision and plan your career and
achieve your true potential so that you
can get the set yourself apart as as big
data professionals and achieve the best
roles and projects that are out there
so uh we have with us uh lillian pearson
uh here she's a
experienced big data scientist with more
than 14 years of work experience
she's also the author of three very
highly referenced technical books uh
data science for dummies big data hadoop
for dummies and managing big data
workflows
she has spent the last decade
training and consulting for large
organizations in the private sector such
as ibm dell intel and also numerous
government organizations
right from say the us navy to the local
government level
she's also the founder of data mania
it's her
passion
to
be an evangelist for big data and also
she has uh she's a data journalist and
she has shared her
unique uh industry experience and now
how with a lot of people and
i will be handing over the presentation
to
uh lillian pearson
thank you so much aj hi everyone thank
you so much for joining us um welcome to
three steps to a big data role of your
dreams happy wednesday i'm excited to be
presenting for you all today um today
i'm going to discuss i'm going to
clarify what's involved in becoming a
big data architect or engineer but
there's actually a lot more to this
presentation than just that so let's get
started
the first thing i'm going to talk about
today is i'm going to introduce the
topic
and what are the benefits and drawbacks
of establishing a career in big data
after that i'm going to go into the
who's or what's of a big data career
that is who's hiring what positions are
available and what's required to fill
those positions
after that i'll be talking about the big
data architect and engineer career paths
and identifying the skill sets that are
involved in those
and
um follow that with current salary
trends for big data roles how much are
these skills really worth
we're gonna end uh this session today
talking about the next steps you can
take um
to get started in your um i guess you
guys are already
part of the big data hadoop developer
course so it's not get started since
you're already on your way but um
what are the next steps you can take in
the evolution of your
of your training career path
aj already introduced me but i'll just
take a few seconds to
introduce myself i'm lillian pearson i'm
a data scientist a data science educator
and a data journalist i'm also a
professional engineer i author books i
did data science for dummies and
big
big data hadoop for dummies
um
i'm a social influencer and a brand
evangelist in the big data space and
i've actually it's been more than 14
years now i have experience working in
the fields between data science and
spatial data science so anyway enough
about me
let's get started on the webinar um
we're going to talk first about the
benefits of establishing a career in big
data
the most clear and obvious benefits of
establishing a career in big data
is the high level of demand for these
type of professionals and the high
salaries
but
it's really good to consider also the
work environment um for most big data
professionals is
quite friendly and happy
um
the the the companies that are hiring
really want to keep the staff that they
have because of the demand is so high so
they have a lot of flexibility allowing
people to work from home and
um when you're working in the office
just you know really cool laid-back
policies about attire and these sort of
things pizza parties all that so it's
it's a good work environment also um you
will enjoy the benefit of having a
prestigious position because like i said
that the demand is high and in the
supply of these type of professionals is
so low
that um
data analytics and in big data engineers
and architects have a lot of prestige
within an organization also what i
really like is that the work can be
applied to all industries so whatever
your passion is you can find an
opportunity
um
within that industry
and if you look at the work in a broader
picture you're you're doing decision
support so it's pretty meaningful
because you're helping affect change
that would otherwise not be possible um
if you weren't present so
no it's it's meaningful work those are
the benefits of a career in big data so
drawback is that of course the work's
really technical so you have to spend a
lot of time and effort um getting
trained
and then um
there's a lot of responsibility there's
not going to be
a lot of people you can turn to
um to help you get the job done so
um people are going to be looking at you
to perform and to get things right the
first time and um
since there's there's
in there's under supply
of professionals that can work in this
capacity
you're going to be lucky if you have a
good support staff
you're probably going to be having to do
a lot of work
get a lot accomplished on your own
and
um
getting the job of your dreams it might
require a relocation but i'm going to
talk about some um jobs in india and
also jobs in the united states during
this this webinar the last the last
drawback is that a lot of the companies
a lot of the bigger companies are
wanting several years of experience so
overcoming the experience threshold can
be a challenge but not necessarily
so um okay
now that you have a realistic picture of
the career field
let's talk about the who's and what's of
a big data career
who is hiring what positions are
available and what's required to fill
those positions before we narrow in on
the big data architect and engineer
rules i want to at least give you a
little information about the big data
industry at large
although it's not a comp oh this is not
a comprehensive list of all the roles in
the space it will at least give you an
idea of what's happening so i've broken
up
main roles in big data space to dawn to
big data data science and data
visualization so
for those of you on the big data career
path then um
the roles that you're most likely to get
when you when you finish would be a big
data architect or a big data engineer
um for data scientists they work as data
scientists or data analytics engineers
and people data visualization
professionals usually get jobs as data
visualization developers
so that's these are the roles that i'm
going to be talking about today
in this section
starting first with the data
visualization developer role
the purpose of these uh
these type of professionals is to build
data showcasing analytical and visual
monitoring tools
and um to develop data visualization
solutions
and
most of the most of the
the job advertisements out there are
asking for at least a bachelor's degree
and of course skills in html javascript
d3
and the likes
as far as companies that are hiring
data visualization developers
there's gm ibm and the weather company
are actually hiring for data
visualization developers right now but
honestly there are less positions
available for people within the
specialty
turning now to data scientists in the
data analytics engineer role
the purpose of
this type of position of people working
the purpose behind this job is to build
algorithmic models for detecting
patterns in or responding to
high volume real-time big data
um and these type of professionals are
building decision support applications
for analyzing visualizing
and
modeling big data to make better
predictions and drive better results
most of the position descriptions out
there are now asking for a master's
master's degree plus
and um of course skills in python are
sql statistics machine learning and um
of course this a strong subject matter
expertise
right now um
the following companies are hiring for
data scientists there's an under supply
of data scientists as well as data
engineers so
right now you can get a job with indeed
intuit under armor facebook monsanto or
birchworks
and now that you've gotten just a brief
look at other roles within the big data
space
i want to focus more in on the big data
architect and engineer role the purpose
of
these the work these type of
professionals do is to source acquire
collect store process integrate prepare
and perform
simple analysis on massive data sets
as far as the skills in education that
are required most position descriptions
have most uh job ads out there are
asking for
a bachelor's degree
um or or higher training
um and and higher training
as well as skills in hadoop mapreduce
scala spark nosql java um
python among others
the the skill requirement definitely
isn't um limited to that list but you
could expect these uh to see these
requirements in the in the job
advertisements
companies that are hiring for big data
architects and engineers include amazon
ibm
dish network tm
in oracle i want to take a moment now um
just to take you on a little interesting
detour because many times i've seen ads
for positions where companies are hiring
for so and so engineer or so-and-so
developer but then the position
description looks almost identical and
it's hard to tell the difference between
those titles
so i did a little research and i found a
survey by o'reilly from 2015
it really clarified the differences
between the engineer architect and
developer titles in the big data space
survey respondents with the title
architect
uh reported using more d3
java hortonworks and cassandra
and they reported spending more time on
etl and meeting attendance compared to
developers and engineers
the developers reported using
using our programming language less
and using javascript and d3 more
um and they they reported it sounds like
they were working more as data division
excuse me data visualization developers
lastly the engineers reported using less
r excel and sas
and more scala and spark
they reported spending it was less
likely to spend time presenting
um analysis
this brings us to section three of
today's webinar
the big data architect engineer career
path identifying the skills involved
thinking back on what we've learned so
far
big data architects um
report spending more time using java
hortonworks and cassandra
i'm assuming that the java work is for
programming in mapreduce
in the big data engineers are
reporting spending more time working in
scala and spark
and mongodb
just to remind you guys the purpose of
this these types of roles is to source
acquire collect store process integrate
prepare and perform simple analysis on
massive data sets
so what are the stepping stones to a
big data role of your dreams those are
really
mass mastery
gaining mastery and experience in the
skills that are required to
to
carry out the job
those skills include hadoop and
mapreduce spark scala mongodb
cassandra and then
also a lot of the positions are talking
about wanting people to have experience
in impala storm and cough
before going into a more narrow
discussion of these technologies and
skill set
let's see how they all fit to fit and
flow together
so i made this schematic here
it's really simple but it kind hopefully
gets the point across
you can see here that um
at the base you've got the data storage
layer
where you've got hadoop um
the hdfs and mapreduce
you've got node sql databases and also
apache
operating in the data storage later then
above that you've got the data
processing layer and you've got either
batch processing tools like mapreduce or
real-time processing tools um
that are either in memory applications
or no sql
applications
and then uh up top you've got the data
consumption layer which i've just
included all the analytics and data
science work within that layer
so
we're going to look here at where does
hadoop fall
fall within the big picture of course
it's going to fall within the data
storage layer with hdfs
acting as the file system storing data
and mapreduce doing the processing work
so it's
it's on the data storage and data
processing layer
now i wanna we're gonna now take some
time to get a more in-depth look at all
these skills and technologies that go
into
uh
big data engineering and big data
architecture
for each technology i'm going to be sure
to emphasize the basics of what that
technology does and how it fits in the
bigger picture picture of a big data
solution
i'm sure you guys are mostly all aware
because you're already enrolled in this
course but hadoop is an open source
framework for collecting processing and
storing big data it uses the hadoop hdfs
to store massive volumes of data
and mapreduce for carrying out
large-scale batch processing jobs
i want to add here that according to the
cio website um
research analysis research analysis they
carried out people with hadoop skills
are earning 13.7
percent
percent more salary than just say uh
software engineers without the hadoop
um developer skills
so what hadoop does the hadoop framework
stores huge volumes of big data on
commodity servers across cluster
it also processes that data using the
mapreduce parallel processing engine
how how do you fit in the the
broader picture of a big data technology
system the hagep framework acts as a
data storage and a data processing
application
it stores data in redundancy across
nodes on commodity servers
it also uses mapreduce to batch process
huge volumes of data
okay now you've seen
where hadoop and mapreduce fit in
but let's move on to some of the other
types of technology you may be less
less aware of
first we're going to talk about spark
spark is an application that fits into
the data processing layer it's an end
memory application a real-time
processing tool
according to the apache spark website
they've defined spark as a fast and
general engine for large-scale data
processing
it allows you to run programs up to 100
times faster than
than mapreduce
in memory or 10 times faster faster on
disks
so when i think of spark
for me i think of real-time analytics
from streaming big data sources because
that's one thing you can do with um
apache spark and as a data scientist
that's the most interesting um
purpose for spark
in my opinion
but let's look what does what spark does
spark is a general processing engine
that is used to carry out
batch processing as well as real-time
processing ad-hoc data querying and even
machine learning
looking at where spark fits in spark is
a real-time data processing application
that's used to process and analyze all
varieties and velocities of big data
the same cio source cited that
spark and scholar skills can get
employees up to fifteen thousand dollars
more per year in earnings
turning now to nosql
it's on the data processing layer as
well as the data storage layers it's a
database it's a database application
what node sql databases do most equal
databases use a variety of database
technologies to store and retrieve both
non-relational and relational data
there are four types of no simple
database those are key value stores
graph databases document stores
and column stores
where nosql databases fit in most sql
databases are part of the data storage
layer of a big data system they're used
for storing and quickly retrieving
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data
we're going to talk about mongodb
and cassandra
today those are both
types of nosql databases
first looking at mongodb
mongodb is a document-oriented type of
nosql database it uses dynamic schemas
and storage data and a model that is
very similar to that of json
it's the most popular type of documents
store on the market
what it does mongodb uses a dynamic
schema to store document files in a
flexible storage model the flexibility
of this model allows for rapid adoption
and advancement during development
mongodb acts as both a data storage
application and a real-time data
retrieval application for
document files so that's the thing you
want to remember about
mongodb is that it's a nosql database
for document files
and according to the um
cio website
mongodb professionals are earning 16.5
percent more salary
than than their counterparts
looking at the cassandra
the cassandra solution
um
cassandra is an open source project in
the second generation distributed nosql
database it's the best choice for higher
availability and scalability of the
database according to
simply learn
and
it's a very popular type of key value
store
no sql database
what cassandra does
apache destroy saunders stores and
manages large amounts of key value
paired data across a cluster of
commodity servers
it acts as both a data storage
application and a real-time data
retrieval application for key value data
so when you when you think of
cassandra you want to think of q value
a key value store
now we're going to look at apache kafka
that's located on the data storage layer
apache kafka is an open source highly
distributed and fault tolerant message
broker designed for accommodating
real-time data feeds
it's written in scala
according to simply learn it's the
preferred messaging platform for
processing big data in real time and
fast processing with real-time message
feeds
what kafka does
kafka is a publish subscribe messaging
system that's used for maintaining
message feeds on a topic by topic basis
as a data storage application
kafka replicates and stores messages
across several nodes for built-in fault
tolerance
and where kafka fits in it's a
distributed data storage platform that
accommodates require requirements
involved in real-time message
data processing
next we're going to look at another and
memory application called impala
and it sits in the data processing
impala is a popular type of massively
parallel processing database
and you use it as a sql engine
to bypass map reduce and query data
directly from the hdfs
what it does is it sits on top of the
hdfs and allows users to
use sql
to perform fast ad-hoc queries of data
that's stored
stored there
so empower a lot of times is used by
data scientists in order to get the data
out of the hdfs without having to
without having to work with mapreduce
where it fits in impala is an in-memory
data processing application that sits on
top of the hdfs
according to the cio source
you can expect
impala and professional and policy
skills are earning
16.5 percent more salary than their
counterparts
and this brings um
now that you understand these skills and
technologies are it's time for me to
introduce you to the steps you can take
to help you get the big data position of
your dreams
step one is to get trained as a big data
and hadoop developer so congratulations
to all of you because you've already
you're already enrolled in training for
that and may have even completed that
first step so pat yourself on the back
for that the next step is to get trained
in spark scala and mongodb and then the
third step would be to get trained in
cassandra but if you really want to
optimize your return on investment here
you'll take an extra step to hybridize
your skill set
so i would add a step four
hybridize your skill set by getting
trained in a polished storm and or
graphical
these will get you prepared so that for
the higher earning positions
um in the market
you'll see what i mean in a minute but
let's just start
by next looking at the current salary
trends for big data rules
and then i'll show you how these hybrid
rules
are where people are earning most uh
most
the highest salaries
section four we're at section four now
and this is where we're going to discuss
salary rules and trends and the big data
architecture
and engineering
positions
just to refresh your mind remember the
irali
data science salary survey where big
data architects reported
mostly using um
using more of java
and cassandra and hortonworks and big
data engineers were reporting working
with scala at spark and mongodb
let's see the demand this map shows the
demand or the number of positions open
for big data engineers in the united
states you can see that
washington dc
actually has the highest number of
openings with 757 and then followed by
san francisco and seattle but there's
there's thousands of openings for big
data engineers in the united states at
this at this time
and um
not to fred because also in india there
are a lot of
a lot of positions even more openings in
india so for people with hadoop skills
there are 300
and
um
3193 positions open
for spark skills there's 1
379 positions open
for people with no sql skills there's
2976 positions open you guys can read
this but
the point is is that there's a lot of
opportunity for big data engineers in
india as well the source for this
information comes from
indeed
india
look at how much money big data
engineers are earning in the united
states
i want to emphasize
here that when you look at this
these are big data engineer positions
but if you take big data professionals
for the full spectrum of skills what i
call hybrid hybridization
um
they have even higher earnings potential
than these numbers but you can see that
um
of course in san francisco big data
engineers are making the most
money at about almost
140 000 a year
and then over in washington dc where
there's more demand
um they're earning slightly less at 125
000 per year
and
over in seattle
where they also have a lot of demand uh
people are earning about 127 000 per
year
now i looked into the
um to the
what i could find about these annual
salaries in india it looks like pay
scale has some good data
and um it at least provided some
information about the data analyst data
scientists invented architect uh rules
there
data analysts are earning 441
000 rupees as an annual salary data
scientists are
earning 1.3 million rupees as a data
seller as a
annual salary and big data architects
earn just over 2 million rupees per year
and all those hybrid roles where you can
earn the real big bucks
this is what i was talking about
these are the these are the big data
professionals that have mastered both
aspects of architecture and engineering
plus some so
you can see that a professional with
skills on hadoop kafka cassandra spark
scala and mongodb
um are earning up to 140 000 per year
but then of course the the demand for
these positions is lower so there's
about 101 job center asking for all of
these skill sets
i'll just take you through a few more
because
you can look and kind of see for
yourself what you're interested in but
um
kafka hadoop cassandra spark and mongodb
a position that requires all of those
skills there's 106 of them and they're
they're averaging out at salaries of
about 133
000 per year
and then for people with skills in
hadoop cassandra spark and mongodb
which are what you will pick up just by
following the the basic three steps that
we laid out for you
they're earning a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars per year and there's
195 positions
um currently available in in the united
states
um all of this data is coming from
indeed.com
so now you understand um
what these technologies and skill sets
are and how they integrate together to
form a big data solution
we want to
discuss with you the next next steps to
take
i'm going to turn it over to aj for that
and then if you have questions make sure
to put them in the question client so
that i can get to them and um
in in our q a session after your poll
okay sorry i was just reading some
questions about titles beyond um
developer
so of course we've discussed architect
engineer and developers but then there's
also going to be big data scientists
analysts and specialists i've seen all
of these types of titles
within position descriptions and
they're used loosely um
so i felt pretty lucky to have found
that survey where people actually
responded and kind of gave a
better definition of what of what
they're doing as engineers and
architects
but um
for the most part when you're looking at
job ads you have to kind of just
decipher between them and see which ones
are most interesting to you and the ones
that you're best qualified for so
um
someone asked
yeah yeah
lillian uh we have a question from
indranil
he has a question saying how typically
how long does it gain uh take to gain
all these skill sets
so imagine if he's going for a big data
hadoop architect he wants to know how
much time will he take to achieve the
skill set i think that depends on the
amount of time you have to invest um
in your training like how if you're if
you have a full-time position and you're
just working on your coursework at night
then um and taking at a slow pace then
you
could spend two years
doing something like that but if you are
working steadily on getting trained and
and experienced i don't wanna um i don't
want to understate that
that the importance of also getting
experience
um
i'd say six to nine months
to get through the series that that
assembly learn has laid out
it also depends on your background
though because um depending on the skill
sets you already have
and the programming what programming
languages you already know it could take
longer or it could take less time
and uh just to add from a statistical
perspective usually uh the full-length
courses that simply iran has we have
seen that
average learners usually take about two
months to finish your course
and the shorter courses usually they
take about three to five weeks so that
gives you an estimate of
how much
time the whole skill set will take
and uh
uh
this question that
if i had to
choose among these skills how would i
prioritize them i know hadoop but if i
have which is the next skill that i have
to pick
well okay so that goes back to the
three-step
the three-step process that we've
discussed um
use mongodb
spark and scala
of course this as step two and then take
the cassandra
courses step three
and then i would suggest taking some
other courses like in impala
or kafka
as well if you really want to
get yourself a better position
lillian we have a question from jyoti
uh she wants to know that she's she says
she's not from a developer background
but she has been working she has been an
erp professional for the last 15 years
so she wants to know how she can you
know develop her profile so that she can
work in big data
i
if she has i.t experience then um
i mean she just needs to get trained and
start working on projects
i
i don't know her background
um
so i can't really say exactly what she
would specifically need to do
okay
and abhishek has a question uh so he's
actually from a quality assurance
background he has about
10 years of experience he's got his
hadoop certificate and he's a little
confused about which area to go towards
so
you would want to know if you can throw
some more light on that
i think that's kind of a personal
question because he needs to
i mean i think that this is sort of i i
thought that they were going to talk to
you about uh kind of career guidance of
like that comes on to what his passion
is
and
um yeah
so we'll have somebody with our career
conduct and connect with abhishek so
that we can take up the matter
personally and uh we have a question
from by sandra where he talks about he's
asking what is the difference can you
elaborate on the difference between
mongodb and cassandra
yeah so both of them are nosql databases
but mongodb is used as a document store
and cassandra is for a key value pair of
data
so that's the largest i mean the the
most glaring difference between them
has a question which is uh more related
to the data scientist so he wants to
know
because we went into detail on the big
data architect role he wants to know
what kind of skill set would you
recommend for being a data scientist in
the us
so if you want to work as a data
scientist then you definitely need to
get turned to either r or python and sql
and then um
i don't think that it it professionals
make the best best data scientist
because usually their subject matter
expertise isn't as specialized as it
needs to be to derive insights
um
when when they're when they're analyzing
data
so
i guess you would need to kind of get
some experience in what your subject
matter expertise is and
machine learning
and data visualization and work on
um having solid communication skills as
well
yeah
that they're working in the financial
domains
and if you yeah if you have a strong
subject and matter expertise in in
in finance
and
you're interested in data analysis and
taking
taking data derived from big data
sources and helping us
in decision support helping to advance
businesses then data scientist sounds
like a good
role for you
uh i think william will come to the end
of our questions thanks a lot for
patiently answering all our queries uh
to all the participants uh we will be
sharing the recording of this webinar
with you so that you can refer back to
it and also if you uh
you can get in touch with it also the
people who had personalized web you'll
have our career consultants reach out to
you
thanks a lot lillian thanks a lot for uh
sharing your time with us hope you
benefited from this webinar and you
choose simple learn to partner
for your career success going forward
too thanks a lot
you